hey ich bin natalie und diese woche gibt
es bei place sowie stars & stories von
und mit sophie richie die eine ziemlich
abgehobene geburtstagsparty feiert model
betis habe die uns exklusiv über ihre
tattoos erzählt und vielen vielen mehr
mit ihren schul streiks und der fridays
for future bewegung wurde greta thunberg
weltweit bekannt 2019 2020 setzte sie
ein komplettes schuljahr aus segelte
über den atlantik trat vor den vereinten
nationen auf und diskutierte unter
anderem mit barack obama und leonardo
dicaprio über den klimawandel
diese woche kehrte sie ins gymnasium
zurück und teilt ihr über instagram mit
das ist großartig ist endlich wieder in
der schule zu sein
in amerika gibt es erneut einen fall von
polizeigewalt gerade einmal drei monate
nach dem tod des afro amerikaners george
floyd zeigen kameraaufnahmen die
polizisten familienvater jacob black in
anwesenheit seiner kinder sieben mal in
den rücken schießen
[Applaus]
dieser liegt nun im krankenhaus sein
zustand ist kritisch
viele promis zeigten in den sozialen
medien ihre erschütterung und wut über
den erneuten fall von polizeigewalt
sängerin demi lovato schreibt wie kann
so etwas immer noch passieren
basketballspieler lebron james schreibt
in einem emotionalen tweed das ist so
falsch und so traurig wir verlangen
gerechtigkeit
dieser traurige vorfall zeigt wie
wichtig die black live mörder bewegungen
nach wie vor ist das betonte auch fc
bayern spieler david alaba der nach dem
sieg im champions league finale mit
einem t shirt mit der aufschrift lag
lifestyle meter über den platz lief hier
sind ein starkes zeichen
[Applaus]
weniger politisch dafür unsere
dekadenter feierte model sophie richie
in 22 geburtstag
die tochter von soul legende lionel
richie flog mit ihren freundinnen einen
privatjet nach los cabos dabei ließen es
die gäste an bord des 40 millionen
dollar teuren gold stream jets so
richtig krachen
mit dabei waren unter anderem bruder
mizrachi und stacy die beste freundin
von kylie jenner
nach ein paar gläsern wurden dann auch
videos von treffen gepostet
[Musik]
während die einen aussergewöhnlichen
zeigen die anderen außergewöhnliche
liebesbekenntnisse gerade erst haben
jimi blue ochsenknecht und seine
freundin jedes ihre beziehung öffentlich
gemacht und schon tätowieren sie sich
gegenseitig die beiden haben sich nicht
nur unter die nadel getraut sondern auch
dahinter
während jedes jimmy ein smiley
tätowierte hat jimmy sich mit einem
kleineren herz für ein etwas
romantisches motiv entschieden
ich muss irgendwas von sieben remis blue
und jedes sind allerdings nicht die
einzigen promis die besondere tattoos
bevorzugen in unseren entscheid zeigen
wir euch jetzt die tattoos der kombis
und die außergewöhnlichen stellen an
denen sie diese manchmal haben
[Musik]
model betty tauber hat sich beim stechen
ihrer tattoos zwar für einen profi
entschieden umso außergewöhnlicher sind
jedoch die stellen an denen sie diese
hat und hat sie mehr zu ihren tattoos
erzählt place to me wie jetzt habe ich
ja eingekleidet tattoos was jetzt nicht
außergewöhnliche arbeit die stellen wo
ich manche tattoo habe sind schon
außergewöhnlich zum beispiel habe ich
angst meine lippe aha da steht brave und
ich habe seit zwei tagen eine kleine
wolke in meiner hand aber nicht so stolz
drauf und ich werde dann immer gesagt
tut das nicht mega mega bkw alle haben
mich gefahren sogar meine titel wäre
dann hat gesagt bist du dir sicher dass
das mit die schmerzhafte stelle die es
zum tätowieren gibt und ich dachte so
genau wo wir sicher und er hat sie
angefangen und so sehr unangenehmen sehr
unangenehm aber es war auch völlig
auszuhalten aber dazu muss ich sagen
dass ich diese art von schmerz
eigentlich voll war ich finde das
irgendwie beruhigend wenn wir das war
sehr schmerzhaft du musst dir doch so
vorstellen als mentoren netz annehmen
würde
und tatsächlich ein fachbüro einmal so
besitzen würde also team
ich glaube jedem ist das
schmerzempfinden anders aber über und in
den stollen besitzerin einer kleinen
brücke auch dominik erlitten hat sich
vor ein paar tagen wieder unter die
nadel gelegt dieses mal gibt es ein ganz
besonderes motiv der youtuber ist
bekannt für seine vielen tattoos und
macht mit seinem letzten nun eine
liebeserklärung der besonderen art an
seine beiden töchter - und keiner sein
handrücken zeigt nun ein märchenschloss
in kombination mit den sternzeichen
seiner prinzessinnen die liebe zu ihren
kindern trägt auch model amber rose
unter der haut und dafür hat sie eine
ganz besondere stelle gewählt
die ex von kanye west hat sich anfang
des jahres die namen ihrer söhne auf die
stirn tätowieren lassen
wenn das ihren
pesch und / nicht beweis wie sehr sie
mama am herzen liegen aber nicht nur die
liebe zur familie wird bei den promis
durch tattoos zum ausdruck gebracht auch
freundschafts tattoos liegen hoch und
trennt die models kaya gerber und kerl
berlin haben sich stadt dem englischen
soulmate mit was so viel wie
seelenverwandt bedeutet das wort
soulmate nur mit tätowieren lassen
damit sind sie für übersetzung nun ganz
offiziell sohlen verband doof nur dass
das tattoo gar nicht auf der fußsohle
ist das wichtigste ist doch dass man
sich in seiner haut wohlfühlt und das
zeigt auch unsere inspiration of the
week
[Musik]
stars präsentieren sich auf instagram
häufig unter dem motto mehr schein als
sein und zeigen ihre vermeintlich
makellosen körper in einer perfekten
welt
mittlerweile wollen viele diesen fake
bild ein ende machen und setzen sich für
mehr realität in den sozialen netzwerken
ein
unsere inspiration of the week kommt
deshalb diese woche von hanna müller
hillebrand auch bekannt als namaste
hanna sie zeigt sich und ihren körper
immer mal wieder auf instagram in
vorteilhaften und bewusst
unvorteilhaften posen dazu schreibt sie
können wir nicht alle akzeptieren dass
unsere körper unterschiedlich aussehen
und dass ein und derselbe körper von
einem moment auf den anderen völlig
anders aussehen kann
wir geben heimrecht und damit war's das
auch schon wieder von place to be stars
& stories
wenn du noch mehr stars & stories
möchtest dann folgt uns auf instagram at
place to be
[Musik]
[Applaus]